[Music]
on this Thursday night no longer on the
run the FBI arrests this former Canadian
military reservist and suspected
recruiter for a neo-nazi group we have
received credible intelligence the
imminent attack Patrick Matthews and
others are accused of plotting millions
of Canadians in the Deep Freeze the cold
hard facts about this cold snap
contradicting the American president
about the Ukraine scandal President
Trump know exactly what was going on an
associate of trumps own lawyer on the
record plus a $700,000
hockey penalty to all the morning murder
why a judge is ordering a beer league
player to pay up
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a major break in the
investigation into a former Canadian
Army reservist who was alleged to have
ties to a neo-nazi group Patrick
Matthews has been arrested by the FBI
nearly five months after disappearing
from his home in Manitoba for months the
FBI but investigating a notorious
neo-nazi group known as the base police
believe they were planning to travel to
a pro-gun rally next week in Virginia
fearing violence at that rally the
state's governor declared a state of
emergency Matthews now faces two weapons
charges in the u.s. in our top story
tonight Mike Jarrell a explains what
more we know four months after Patrick
Matthews disappeared at the Manitoba
border he lived in the shadows until the
FBI knocked down the door of the
Delaware apartment he was renting
he was arrested along with two other
alleged members of an aggressive
neo-nazi group called the base this
morning they felt that they had to act
right because these guys had you know
they had guns they had 1600 rounds of
ammunition they had best for body armor
right so you know it seemed like they
might have been up to they might have
been up to no good
Matthews had trained to be an explosives
expert in the Canadian Forces Global
News had previously reported he had been
the subject of a covert military
intelligence investigation for his
alleged beliefs but it was a Winnipeg
Free Press report into his suspected
role as a trainer and recruiter for the
base that led to his disappearance and
based on an affidavit filed today it
seems the FBI was watching him closely
because he was you know former Canadian
Army a combat engineer you know I'm told
he was extremely motivated right and you
know it seemed like he might be willing
to to to you know to engage in violent
hate crime experts say the base is a
group that believes in triggering a race
war so that they can create an ethe no
white state so these acceleration as as
we refer to them are very keen not just
to wait for you know the great masses to
wake up and to recognize you know their
their loss of place but are happy to
engage in
what might be offensive violence such as
defensive violence the timing of the
arrests coincides with a state of
emergency declared in Virginia just days
before a planned a pro-gun rally is set
to take place US authorities have
reported an increase in online chatter
between alt-right groups planning to
attend including the base we have
received credible intelligence from our
law enforcement agencies that there are
groups with malicious plans for the
rally that is planned for Monday this
includes out of state militia groups and
hate groups if convicted Matthews faces
up to ten years in prison for each of
the two weapons related charges he's
facing microlight Global News Toronto
the other top story of the day is the
weather from coast to coast to coast
Canadians are dealing with powerful
winds heavy snowfall and extreme cold
Environment Canada has issued weather
alerts many of them extreme cold
warnings in every single province and
territory in the country roughly 20
million Canadians are caught in this
warned to brace for potentially
dangerous weather conditions hardest hit
is almost the entire province of Alberta
gripped for another day of roughly minus
45 with the windchill Global's Quin
Oller is in Edmonton tonight Quin it's
been so cold there for so long how
people doing with what well Donna it has
been so cold for so long and it's
dangerous so people are really bundling
up staying inside as much as they can
and if they do have to be outside
they're making their way inside with
lots of breaks as I mentioned it's
dangerously cold here I've lived here my
entire life and I feel like this is the
longest that it has been this cold and
that we've dealt with this today here in
Edmonton we had a high of minus 26
degrees minus 37 when you factor in the
wind chill now that actually seems
pretty warm for what we've been dealing
with over the last couple of days
colder here than the self pool other
parts of our province are seeing minus
40 or minus 50 with the windchill Edmund
Toni ins are used to it though we're
doing what we can and dreaming of those
warmer days Donna I bet you are Quin
Oller in Edmonton thanks well Canadians
aren't used to the cold of course and it
is the middle of winter but even in
Manitoba the Deep Freeze of minus 33 was
a bit much today
Britney Greenslade reports the trails
are groomed the rinks flooded and ready
but these normally bustling winter
activity spots are empty this is a
little bit extreme I don't think there's
too many brave souls out there today
today the entire province of Manitoba
hit temperatures below minus-30 at times
the extreme cold even too cold for most
Winnipeggers no I don't go outside
anymore I just don't want like four
weeks of it in a row the temperatures
hit dangerously low levels where
frostbite can occur within minutes
leaving the city's most vulnerable
looking for places to stay warm
that blanket say that I got a heater and
I got myself night my artpad and runs
while others are still searching after
the city was forced to dismantle a
homeless camp after a tepee caught fire
when a resident fell asleep with a camp
fire still burning they lost some of
that housing with the teepee that burned
down anyway so they were really within
their own encampment struggling to have
space the weather's dipped very very
cold now and while the cold has most
people rushing to the indoors others are
still trying to make the best of it I
don't think I could ever get too cold
for us now today in Winnipeg it was
minus 33 but that windchill made it feel
more like minus 45 but there is some
good news in the forecast tomorrow it's
expected to warm up to a balmy minus 10
Donna
whoo-hoo brittany Greenslade in winnipeg
thanks meteorologist Ross hull is at the
Global News Weather Center Ross what's
in store for the rest of the West Donna
still some extreme cold to deal with
across the prairies for the end of the
week into the weekend so BC Alberta
into Saskatchewan but then as the
weekend progresses in the next week that
cold moves out and a Pacific flow moves
in so some milder air in fact
above-average temperatures expected for
many parts of the southern Prairie
should enough conditions likely around
southern Alberta and with that Pacific
flow some steady rain for the BC coast
and milder conditions the combination of
the two could bring some flooding so
that is a story to watch in the coming
days now that cold air barreling east
combining with some Atlantic moisture a
blizzard on the way to Newfoundland
Friday into the early part of Saturday
this system will be intensifying it will
be a weather bomb meaning it's pressure
dropping at least 24 millibars within 24
hours
strong winds some areas could see 70
centimeters of snow across the avalon
coupled with winds of around 150
kilometres per hour the system moves out
on Saturday and there's likely another
system on the way for early next week
winter is just getting started Donna
okay Ross hull thanks there's a new
international demand for answers about
how and why Iranian missiles shot down
that passenger plane in Iran foreign
ministers from Canada and the four other
countries which lost citizens met today
at the Canadian High Commission in
London they paid tribute to the 176
people who died and then sat down to
hash out a list of demands for Iran as
crystal commencing reports the question
is getting around to cooperate bonded by
grief government leaders from Canada
Ukraine Sweden Afghanistan and Britain
put their unity on display a moment of
silence quickly moving to a meeting and
a list of diplomatically worded demands
for Iran I think what the world is
asking today is full accountability and
full transparency and full cooperation
by Europe the Canadian led group agreed
to 5 points during the day-long meeting
key among them international observers
involved in every step of Iran's
investigation they're also calling for
Iran to identify victims remains with
dignity an independent and credible
criminal investigation compensation and
accountability for those responsible
that's where the Netherlands comes in
they were invited because of their
experience dealing with a long and
detailed investigation of down Malaysia
Airlines flight 17 in 2014 the passenger
plane was shot down over eastern Ukraine
298 people died I know how important it
is to the relatives and friends of the
deceased to achieve Iran did take
responsibility for shooting down Ukraine
International Airlines flight 752 last
week but it's pulling the united states
into its circle of blame saying ongoing
fighting had members of its
Revolutionary Guard on edge all parties
are urging Iran to keep cooperating we
will judge Iran when it comes to the
investigation as to whether
international experts will be allowed to
join in the investigation we judge Iran
on the fact that in the case of Canada
because you were asking me the Transport
Safety Board two experts are now in
Tehran and we have offered also to have
experts being there to help when the
black box are going to be open Canada
was delayed in getting to the crash site
by several days officials were in Turkey
waiting for visas to be approved so not
all requests are being dealt with in a
timely fashion at this point the
grieving Nations can only assume that
Iran wants to be seen as a cooperative
player in the eyes of the international
community Donna
crystal commencing in London thanks
Ontario is creating 57 post-secondary
scholarships to honor the Canadian
victims of flight 75 to premier Doug
Ford says the scholarships will be
$10,000 each they'll be awarded on
academic merit and financial need more
than a dozen post-secondary institutions
in Ontario law students or faculty
members in the disaster the tensions in
the Middle East appear to have eased a
little bit allowing the Canadian Forces
to resume some operations in Iraq
Global's investigative reporter Stewart
Bell is in Kuwait City tonight the
headquarters of Canada's
in Iraq Stuart it's been just over a
week since the Canadian military put
their operation in Iraq on pause
following the u.s. airstrike that killed
the Kurds force leader Qasem Soleimani
but Thursday the military did say that
some of their operations had now resumed
that includes transport flights into
Iraq to supply the troops and some
special operations activities have also
been allowed to carry on now under what
the military is calling strict
parameters we are constantly assessing
the threat we are constantly making
decisions that would be applicable to
ensure the protection of the force and
positioning ourselves to be ready to
whatever comes next the United States
has also returned to its fight against
Isis in northern Iraq but a Canadian
military spokesperson said that safety
remained the priority for the Canadian
troops and that the training mission
remained on hold for now
Stuart Bell Global News Kuwait City
another legal hurdle has been cleared
for the trans mountain pipeline
expansion project the Supreme Court of
Canada has dismissed an appeal of a
lower court ruling it found
interprovincial trade is federal
jurisdiction and the flow of commodities
like heavy oil and bitumen should be
overseen by federal regulators BC was
trying to fight that the project was
sold to the federal government for 4.5
billion dollars it will nearly triple
the capacity of the existing trans mount
in pipeline that carries oil from
Edmonton to Burnaby BC President Trump
called a liar coming up conflicting
stories on who knew what in the campaign
to pressure Ukraine
the plot is thickening in the
impeachment trial of President Trump a
man who played a central role in the
campaign to pressure Ukraine to
investigate political rivals of
President Trump is talking and Lev Perez
says the president despite his denials
was fully aware of the efforts to dig up
damaging information in an interview on
MSNBC he said Trump knew exactly what
was going on he said about you and mr.
Froman Iger Fuhrman I don't know those
gentlemen I don't know about them I
don't know what they do you're saying
that was not a true statement from the
president he lied
Barna says he regrets trusting President
Trump and his personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani and wants the world to know the
truth
that's what the impeachment trial is
working towards to Jackson Frost Co has
the latest developments on that do you
solemnly swear that in all things a
pertaining to the trial of the
impeachment of Donald John Trump
President of the United States now
pending you will do impartial justice
according to the Constitution and the
laws so help you God I do swearing in
the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court
and the 100 US senators who will act as
jurors so help you God
the impeachment trial of President
Donald Trump began in earnest with two
articles abuse of power and obstruction
of Congress hand-delivered to the Senate
for consideration quickly it's a hoax
it's a hoax everybody knows that it's a
it's a complete hoax the White House
wants a short trial and a speedy
acquittal at the hands of the Republican
majority President Trump know exactly
what was going on but a bombshell
interview with Lev Parnas a former
associate of trumps lawyer Rudy Giuliani
could change all that he was aware of
all of my movements
heeey I wouldn't do anything without the
consent of Rudy Guiliani or the
president Parnas was involved in the
alleged White House scheme to pressure
Ukraine to investigate Trump's rival Joe
Biden I don't know him at all don't know
what he's about don't know where he
comes from know nothing about him the
new claims are fueling calls for the
impeachment trial to hear from witnesses
something Republicans and the president
have rejected the very integrity of the
United States Senate is on trial the
precedent in impeachment trials in the
Senate is to have witnesses the White
House is also managing the fallout from
a damaging new report from the US
Government Accountability Office which
says the administration broke the law by
withholding military aid to Ukraine I
have never ever seen a report like this
as all that unfolded in Washington
Ukraine's government announced an
investigation of its own not into Joe
Biden as Trump had once wanted but into
reports that former US ambassador to
Ukraine Marie Ivanovitch had been under
illegal surveillance by Associates of
Rudy Giuliani before she was dismissed
from her post by the White House Jackson
the impeachment trial begins next week
how is it expected to unfold well Donna
it's going to start on Tuesday it will
run six days per week including
Saturdays until it's over exactly how
long it lasts though remains an open
question as does the question of whether
or not witnesses will be called one of
the oddities here Donna is that even
though senators are supposed to be the
jurors in this trial they also get to
set the rules for how it's all going to
unfold
Jackson another big piece of news from
the Senate today about a trade deal what
happened yes this is the deal to replace
NAFTA Kozma as it's known in Canada u.s.
MCAS it's known here in the US it was
passed by the Senate it now goes to
president Trump's desk for a signature
when that happens still a question
either way you slice it it's a major win
for Trump to have this deal done all
right Jackson Prosecco in Washington
Thanks a head beer lead breakthrough how
a hockey players costly penalty has put
the games rules on thin ice
you
this next story is a cautionary tale for
anyone who plays recreational hockey an
Ontario man has been ordered to pay more
than 700 thousand dollars after injuring
a fellow player the hit happened back in
2012 and according to a judge the
injured player hasn't been the same
since
Abagail Beaman looks at the case and how
the hockey community is reacting I'm
terrified of my kid getting it tonight
Dave Ross refereed hockey for 40 years
and has seen his fair share of violence
on the ice they just changed actually
changed the rule now a minor hockey so a
minor penalty for checking from behind
is now an automatic one game suspension
but it's not just a problem in minor
hockey
I won't referee men's hockey anyway
because I can't deal with all the crap
that goes on an Ontario Court ruled one
beer league player has to pay another
seven hundred thousand dollars in
damages for slamming into him during the
last minute of a game in 2012
temporarily knocked unconscious the
judge found drew caster Dan's brain
injury left him with permanent damage
and he has never returned to the life he
enjoyed before the hit 700 thousand
votes a lot of mourning with your
30-plus years old the NHL is not calling
anymore you know have fun have a good
time
after years of criticism the NHL has
slowly moved to take headshots more
seriously but contact still counts for a
lot
body checking physical contact is
something that's part of the game has
been forever and that's something that
makes the game exciting appealing
entertaining Hockey Canada has been
proactive banning body checking for
players under 13 well I wasn't surprised
it is something we're starting to see
trend up and the Canadian adult
recreational Hockey Association offers
members liability insurance at a cost of
$23 a year what I think we're going to
see is maybe municipalities are gonna
start to mandate liability another sign
the game so many of us love is evolving
at all competitive levels as our
understanding of head injuries does -
Abigail Beeman global news Ottawa neck
saying goodbye to a legend from
Newfoundland and Labrador
there was a rare gathering of political
leaders in Newfoundland and Labrador
today Prime Minister Trudeau joined by
former prime ministers and a host of
political leaders and former cabinet
ministers all of them there to honor the
passing of John Crosbie who died at the
age of 88 he was controversial he was a
servic and he was charismatic and he was
remembered today for his abiding love of
his province st. John's Church John
Crosbie was laid to rest in a state
funeral his son Chaz remembers him as a
man who loved to laugh and was loyal to
the core for our Father politics was a
calling to service he did it oh so well
Crosby's political career spanned five
decades his son says his honesty often
got him into hot water
the CBC once wrote that he carries
around in that great head a little voice
which murmurs from time to time
go ahead Johnny say it respect for
Crosby cross political lines those who
came to pay tribute included premiers
current and former the prime minister
and two previous ones Joe Clarke and
Brian Mulroney there are very few
Canadians whose leadership contributions
to our country at a Newfoundland and
Labrador will resonate as powerfully and
as durably in history as the body of
work left to us by John Crosby Crosby's
greatest love was his wife Jane they
were married for 68 years there could be
no more powerful example of the strength
and beauty of joining two people than
your strong Union
[Applause]
[Music]
that is global Nashville for this
Thursday I'm donor Friesen tonight's
your Canada is nicola lake near Merritt
BC we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to us and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow bye
bye
[Music]